[Music]
my name is Aston howdy I work for
pivotal and I work on something called
Apache geode that we're going to talk a
little bit about today if you don't know
pivotal software we work with companies
we build tools we have methodologies in
a platform to help big companies make
better software and try to deliver more
business value to their customers I can
tell you way more about that but we need
to answer this question so who's used an
in-memory data grid before in the room
sort of ok I'm glad I didn't see any
hands because you're in the right place
if you could answer this question you
probably shouldn't come to this talk but
I'm glad you guys here so how we're
gonna answer this question I'm gonna
tell you a little bit about how I
stumbled upon in-memory data grids
totally by accident and why I like
working on them really briefly show you
some real-world use cases of customers
I've worked with in the past but more
importantly and we're going to spend the
most amount of our time is we're
actually going to work together to build
an in-memory data grid that sound like
are you guys up for that you guys woman
yeah okay like I'm gonna need your help
so alright and then we're gonna design
an in-memory data grid and then we're
gonna think about some use cases so it's
a little bit you know technology for use
case sake but let's just spend that for
a little bit so memory data grids
provide a lightweight distributed scaled
out in memory object store the grid and
multiple applications can concurrently
perform transactional and analytical
operations and low latency thus minimize
the access for just based systems job
job done definitions there Gartner
solved it for us so first time I read
this this was kind of my thought I just
thought of like a grid and computers but
then someone explained it to me they
drew some pictures and the first thing
that came to my mind was
one seen the movies swordfish okay no
well there's a CNN when Hugh Jackman
does some really awesome hacking and he
creates this thing and it looks like
that and that's what came to my mind was
this grid and we're gonna draw a lot of
boxes look how happy he is see so
alright so two examples of where this is
used it's an extremely low latency use
cases with a lot of throughput so one of
my I find it very interesting to look
outside the US because I think that is
where a lot of the most data intensive
use cases are so for example one of the
customers I work with is a China railway
4 point or 1.4 billion page views per
day 20 million daily users and there are
40,000 visits per second on their site
so really high scale and they need to
deliver a answers that are right every
single time and I mean they're doing a
ticketing system so if I buy a ticket
and that's the last one you can't buy
that ticket and they got to make sure
that that's right
another one is Southwest Airlines I work
with them very closely first just want
to say my condolences to those that were
injured and or lost on 1380 yesterday
and I'm pretty amazed with the
professionalism that they handle that
situation but if you think about what
they have to do is they're tracking over
4,000 daily flights the passengers that
are on that flight that where they are
all of that and they need to do it
correctly so when not to use in-memory
data grids really quickly when you have
small amounts of data latency isn't
mission critical and you need to do some
analytics using sequel like it they will
not replace a traditional relational
data store all right so let's make an
in-memory data grid and this is where
I'm going to need your help so the
design goals of making this system is
going to be extremely low latency
we need high throughput it needs to be
the system needs to be durable so if you
know let's just say someone trips on a
network cord and we need the data to
still be there and to be able recover we
need to support large data sets so the
amount of information that needs to sit
in memory and be accessible is very high
and then we're going to talk about
consistency a little bit and I'm gonna
argue that our system should be
consistent meaning every read gets the
most up-to-date right so how we're gonna
solve that we're gonna go through each
one of these and I this is my proposed
solution to get these answers someone
has a different solution shout out and
say now it's a terrible idea so first I
will say I work on Apache geode I work
on a distribution of Apache geode called
gem fire that pivotal puts out so a lot
of my design decisions are going to be
based off the fact that I know this
system really well and the end solution
is probably going to look a lot like
Apache dia but just want to say that all
right so memory first memory first I
think we should use memory as our first
storage mechanism in the system anyone
disagree all right memory first it is so
why we want to do this has anyone seen
these latency numbers before yes all
right so this was put out by Jeff Dean
and it's attributed to Peter Norvig as
well and it's latency numbers every
engineer should know talking about you
know how long it takes to get stuff out
of an l1 cache all the way down to
sending a packet from California to the
Netherlands and back when I first saw
these numbers I and these are on github
and people update it and stuff this
Hardware gets better but when I first
saw these numbers they didn't really I I
don't think on nanosecond scale like
Jeff Dean like I'm pretty sure Jeff Dean
just
count in nanoseconds but I can't so I
had to scale them up and I looked at
memory an SSD in disk and if you think
about Amazon Prime an Amazon Prime
delivery being how long is the the base
of how long it takes to read one
megabyte from memory and you scale
everything else up that means an SSD
read of that time is going to take nine
days and a disk is going to take eight
months so that's that's the differences
in time now I don't know about you but
I'm really mad at Amazon when they miss
my delivery by like a day let alone nine
days or even eight months so this is
kind of why memory and the use of memory
is so important all right so next thing
we're going to talk about is horizontal
scale we need to be able to add nodes
take away notes from our distributed
system and it all needs to be done in
memory and the fact that it's going to
be horizontally scalable we're gonna be
able to grow our cluster and meet some
of those memory requirements in our
system because I don't have the money to
go out and buy the largest amount of
memory possible to put on one machine we
need a more commodities hardware and
distribute it up so drawing some boxes
and some lines this is how I think about
an in-memory data grid when I draw so
really quickly the colors that are up
here I'm proposing that we do a
client-server architecture or clients
can talk to our server down here I'm
proposing that we have some processes
called locators that constantly watch
the system and make sure like okay what
nodes are talking to what nodes what's
available in the system who's going out
who's going in so that's what they do
but really quickly what we have here is
we have four pieces of data that are
each represented by a different color
and they're distributed throughout the
system and copied twice so the
redundancy level within the in-memory
data grid is two so that means that if a
client produces
some data and again I'm skipping over
the fact this is a key value store it's
a key value object store so I create an
object I have a key I have a value and I
put that in the system the next thing
that's gonna do is it's gonna write here
and then I'm gonna argue that the client
shouldn't get confirmation until it's
copied over at least once because that's
what the user specified the redundancy
level to be so a single write into our
data grid is going to be once here it's
going to be copied here in this case
over here and then the client will say
yep we're good all right so
uh-oh someone tripped over a network
cable in the data center and we lost it
we lost two machines the locators said
can't see him anymore two members of our
grid went down and that data then the
the system will recognize that and copy
the data and balance it between the two
remaining servers that we have so that
horizontal scalability and elasticity
will meet some of those requirements
that we had so if we add another node
back into the system the machine comes
back up
someone restarted the ec2 machine
whatever we have that node back in our
system and the data will be balanced
throughout so now we have this
horizontal scalability everything's in
memory and get super low latency job
done so I mentioned really quickly a
quick aside of where these systems and
our system which looks a lot like Apache
geode falls on the cap theorem well it
depends I made the assumption earlier
that we wanted things to copy
synchronously between those two nodes
now if we had chosen to copy them
asynchronously what do we change in our
system where would we be on the cap
theorem
it would be a P so the system we are
coming up with was sitting here on
consistency and partition tolerance but
if we had changed what we wanted to do
between those two nodes we're going to
sit up here on an AP system now these I
put up here these are all the default
settings in these systems and a lot of
their memory data grids that are out
there they're configurable but I won't
go into that all right so now that we
have this quick aside this is a feature
that I want to add into this in memory
data grid way and replication so we have
this client-server architecture and I
think we should have a circuit ish
communication between the two data
centers that we have up here and this is
one of the really popular features that
a lot of customers that you use today
where if I have a right let's just say a
data center in New York a right happens
we get confirmation back to the client
the two clusters will maintain
consistency over an asynchronous
communication between these two days
data centers using LAN rip wayne
replication that's another feature that
a lot of customers use and i propose
that we put in our in memory data grid
all right the next thing we've done
we've used memory we've used horizontal
scalability to capture similar design
goals the third thing that I think we
need to add is data aware routing if we
go back to that latency diagram what's
the what's this here that's causing a
lot of our latency it's a network so the
network is going to add a lot of latency
so if we have this grid we've we've kind
of designed this grid here every hop on
these black lines is going to really cut
down our latency and we have the data
distribute amongst all these nodes and
when a client wants to do a read it
might go in and say okay the data isn't
here it's been it's actually on a
different part of the system
and that's gonna have another Network
hop so the way to solve this is we need
to add some smarts into the clients to
say and give the client some knowledge
on what node in our grid has what data
and that's what a lot of these systems
do so customer comes in they have a
certain key a certain value they want
the purple object here our client is
going to know that the data is on this
server rather than coming in looking
saying I want the purple one and maybe
again I kind of skipped over something
every one of these clients maintains a
connection with each one of the servers
so if I round-robin through all of those
connections I'm not gonna necessarily
find the data because it's not
replicated on each one of the nodes in
our grid so by adding this single hop
feature into our clients and making our
clients know where the data is we can
skip that really costly Network hop and
get that latency down the next thing
that we can do because our clients have
a little bit of smarts in them is we're
going to add a local cache into our
clients and that'll save us yet another
network hop so a client comes in let's
just say they log in and they have a
session in their browser now since I
have a copy of that that object here in
the client I don't have to go to the
cluster that's saving a big network a
costly network hop but the thing that we
just introduced in the system that has a
lot of complexity is we have to worry
about expiration of that object so if
something changed in the server
something that we added to the system
like a function that's running it says
when a certain threshold gets met change
this object add something we then have
to add a bunch of communication that's
going to happen between the server and
the client to say that locally cached
magenta object-- up there it's old and
you need to get rid of it and here's the
up
so a lot of complexity happens in this
grid but it's going to save us a lot of
latency and that's our big goal
serialization I'm not going to go a lot
into this I feel like we could have it
could have its own track at this
conference just on serialization we'll
have to talk to Pete about that I don't
know if does anyone want to like be a
speaker at serialization track I don't
know it might happen we're getting some
traction but this is a really big piece
of saving latency and increasing
throughput so without going too much
into serialization a there's a lot of
serialization formats the way that
in-memory data grids and I think that we
should solve this is creating our own
serialization format but the three rules
in my head around serialization
serialize and deserialize only when it's
necessary so for example we want if we
go back to our system we want to try to
just read that we don't want to add CPU
costs here in here when we move data
across the wire that's gonna save a lot
of costs in our system so only
deserialize and serialize when it's
absolutely necessary only deserialize
and serialize what you need when you
need it so I'm not gonna get into this
but a lot of these systems support
server-side functions or you can bring
some anarchic and Apache geodes case
date a function to the server that runs
there and you can do things like real
time processing or event queues or
something like that and if we have this
big object that we're storing if we need
to look things up in it and we kind of
take it out of memory and try to look at
it that's gonna be really costly so we
need to be able to look at that object
and the only things that we want in that
object and the last one is we need to
distribute the D serialization costs as
much as possible so if the server is
sitting there doing all that translation
getting the object into one format
another format getting over the wire
if we have that all sitting in our
servers it's going to be really costly
so the thing that I'm going to propose
is that we take that serialization and
we distribute it so that D serialization
back into something like an applications
domain object is going to be done on the
client so now we have all these clients
that we can spin up a lot faster doing
our D serialization work for us
so basic user officer so now we have the
system it's a super low latency high
throughput system that we probably can
have some basic user operations on and
the features that I think we can create
here put and get we've seen that we've
seen that I can take an object I can put
it I can get it from the grid I can do
queries against the grid because we have
all this data sitting in memory and I'd
probably want to look things up so it
supports queries talked a little bit
about server-side functions I can take a
function using the grids api's and I can
deploy it into the grid and use things
like I mentioned event queues or I could
do something that says you know every
few minutes I want you to count how many
objects are in here and give me the
result and put in another part of the
grid simple example we saw a little bit
about registered interest this is a
specific term that is in apache geode
but we talked about how i could have a
client and a server and I could really
want to pay attention to a certain
object or a certain range of keys are in
my system and when someone that changes
I want my client to be notified and
we're going to see some cool use cases
with that there's a similar idea that I
think we're going to we can talk about
around continuous queries where I can
write a query to have my client sitting
there and as soon as something changes I
get notified so let's see that and event
queues so use cases really quickly go
through these inline caching so you
wanna do inline caching today with any
other products
so at a high level what this is
legacy relational data store I'm not
going to name any but I'm sure we've all
seen them in a while they are dispatched
they can be slow but that's the source
of truth in this case we can put our in
memory data grid in front of it and
provide a lot lower latency data access
reads and writes into our data grid or
into our r-mdps
so let's just say we have a user comes
in they'll enter send some information
to a text box and we want to put that in
our database our client is going to
create an object on that it's gonna be
able to put it into our data grid and
then we can say back yep we got it
but asynchronously we can do some right
behind into our database so the data is
getting where it needs to go but from a
user perspective it's getting there much
faster another pattern that's really
common is lookaside caching this is the
case where you have you don't want your
client application to necessarily think
the data grid is a source of truth
that's the subtle difference so in this
case same thing happens I want access to
my my purple object up there from a user
perspective the clients going to go in
it's going to ask for it and the first
thing it's going to do is it's gonna say
yep I don't have it because it's not
cached here the only place that it
resides is in our relational data store
so unfortunately it's gonna have to do
the costly thing it's going to take that
much longer period of time that we saw
to get that object but the next time
it's requested it's going to be in
memory and it could even be cached
locally in one of our clients again all
that expiry stuff would have to happen
make sure that we're actually giving the
best source of truth to the entire
system but we're able to provide a much
better experience for our users because
it's long
faster we've also created a pub/sub
system out of this architecture so some
object changes within our system our
magenta object GRU I've got some more
information because of that register and
interest function that we that we talked
about our client is going to just pay
attention says I really want to know
when the magenta object changes and what
we can do is the first thing will happen
is it changes that change gets brought
out to the rest of the grid and it's
also going to get note our clients are
going to get notified to say yep that
object changes tense pub/sub system can
also do real-time analytics with this
type of architecture because you can
deploy functions into the grid so an
example simple count when a certain
there's an abstraction inside of geode
called regions and that's think about it
if you're coming from relational will
think about like a table so if I go in
and my table gets bigger than a thousand
rows a region has more than a thousand
objects I want you to kick off a
function that I have deployed in here
it's gonna say - it's gonna count
everything and it's going to store that
result and maybe notify something back
so I can deploy and these little I chose
a box to represent a function I don't
know if that's the world's best like a
good choice but it's what Google slides
had so put up a box it's running there
and that result is then gonna get
updated to our client so we can have
this interesting real-time analytics use
case and my clients are being notified
at all times this is probably my
favorite use case that I've seen it's
distributed computation if you go inside
of a lot of banks this is how
derivatives trading actually does a lot
of their work and understands a bank
will understand their position at any
given time so this has been called
scatter gather
it looks a lot like Map Reduce but you
have inside this cluster let's just say
the price of every stock at any moment
in time and we know it's accurate we
know the position of every single order
every single trade and it's consistent
so what we can do is we can then spin up
a bunch of clients and each one of those
clients is going to take a portion of
that data and then we're gonna do maybe
some Monte Carlo analysis on each one of
those clients we're gonna gather those
results back up and say okay what's our
risk on like this point in time within
our system and we can put that result
back into the system and you know map
and reduce and because it's all done a
memory this happens really fast another
thing that a lot of banks do with this
type of architecture is they can run a
lot of pricing models so I don't know if
anyone works at a bank I used to be in
banking and a lot of the models are
written in C++ so what we can do is we
can have clients they're all C++ clients
they have a really sophisticated
derivatives pricing model on each one of
the clients we have real time we have
updated analytics at any point we have
the source of truth here and our grid
and then we can push these out and our
clients can ask for any updated
information on those and we can do a
pricing model on our derivatives at any
time so on a typical trading day these
type of models will get called over a
billion times so that's that's traders
saying okay what's our position here I
need the price here I need the price now
and you have to be able to do this in a
distributed way and in super low latency
using an in-memory data grade if you
want to know more about these types of
system systems I can get ax I can give
you this book it was written by one of
my colleagues Mike Stoltz and this is I
think one of the best published pieces
on in memory data grids if you're
interested in you oughta learn more so
that's all I got if you want to talk
more I think we have a little bit of
time for questions but I don't have
office hours after this
fire away so you mentioned the
registered objects I forget exactly the
term but so does that update
communication only happen if you set up
some kind of function to actually watch
it or is there some kind of tracking of
if it pulls something into its cache it
just does that automatically both yeah
there's both the API there's a in Apache
at least you can set up a local cache
and that will make sure that any updates
happen and there's another way to do it
where you the API its register all keys
or a registered key and you can or you
can give it a range and say I really
want to pay attention to you know for
example anything that's between this
date in this state depending on how you
model your data within you're good for
client caching do you need to sort of to
keep the consistency do you need to
invalidate education on every right so
ensuring that acknowledges received not
from the nodes but also from every
single client yeah so that you're
exactly right so if I did some client
caching just to make sure I understand
the question if I did some client
caching and a write came in from one of
the clients and you're saying that all
the other clients had something locally
cache yeah we would have to send out a
communication to all the other clients
to invalidate that and in the system
does that yeah because you have to I
mean it's an update to this system so
you